these  direction of the country polls that are  always talked about oh people think the  country's going in the wrong wrong  direction everybody interprets them to  mean  that you don't like the person that's  currently president and that's not what  they mean for example i generally  speaking approve of the job that joe  biden has done he's done like a dozen  really good things over the last few  months and i've talked about them  extensively but i think the country's  going in the wrong direction not because  biden but because of these retrograde  authoritarian  wannabe fascists who want the u.s to be  an extreme right-wing christian  dictatorship it's going in the wrong  direction because there's lots of them  around doesn't mean i'm unhappy with  biden doesn't mean i'm thrilled with  everything he's done but we shouldn't  interpret these polls in this way